in my mid-30s I felt tired all the time
I was lethargic all the time and I
genuinely believed that's sort of what
happens when you get to Middle eight
right and here I am at 44. you know and
I'm running rings around 22 year olds
I'm full of energy full of Vitality so
how sad was it that I actually believed
that's sort of how you're meant to feel
and it's not and it wasn't until I got a
bit of space from alcohol that actually
realized what it was doing to me in
terms of that mental Cloud I think that
just hangs around and that's what people
don't realize most people start drinking
their teens they never really stop and
if you think about it if you drink once
or twice a week you're always slightly
under the cloud of alcohol you're not
maybe displaying the classic signs of
nausea and all that sort of stuff like
that's gone the day after if you've got
a bit of a hangover but it affects your
sleep go and look at the science right
alcohol destroys restorative sleep and
then look at the science about poor
sleep it's awful for your productivity
for your motivation for your mental
health so I think people again in this
Middle Lane the moderate drinkers the
average drinkers don't realize what it's
doing to them